[Music]
hey guys I'm Rachel Cruz co-host of the
Ramsey show where we have been answering
your questions about your life and your
money for over 30 years now when my dad
Dave Ramsey first started the show it
aired on one of the struggling local
stations and within 2 years we became
the top rated Radio Show in Nashville
and today the ramsy show is a nationally
syndicated Radio Show podcast and
YouTube channel with billions of
Lifetime views and downloads and the
thing is we still keep growing
especially since launching the show on
video 10 years ago so to celebrate that
Milestone our team decided to look back
and crack open the vault of a decade's
worth of video content for this limited
series Dave Ramsey's Greatest Hits and
guys you are in for a treat with this
episode because what better way to kick
things off than with some of the most
beloved Dave rants of all time so get
ready for some classic Dave and maybe
even a wakeup call that you might need
right
now your income doesn't matter your age
doesn't matter your race doesn't matter
your
geographical location doesn't matter
there's a thing that you and I are
dealing with in your money and it's
called
math and none of those things I just
mentioned give you a pass on
math and where people get themselves in
trouble including when I went broke many
years ago because I was stupid we get
ourselves in trouble when we don't
bother and do the math before we do the
transaction we're the stupid woman from
San Diego who leased her
dog for
$5,400
we make $90,000 a year and somehow in
our brains figure out that our children
deserve a $50,000 Honda
SUV and now we have to take the kids out
of private school because we can't pay
the payments on the SUV and the private
school because we didn't do math we're
21 years old we buy a $10,000 car run up
$110,000 in credit card debt and have
$10,000 in medical bills and make
$30,000
a
year when you make $30,000 a year
there's nowhere in that plan that $3,000
the $10,000 car makes sense there's
nowhere in that plan that running up a
bunch of credit card debt gives you any
room to breathe you already can't
breathe we have three kids we make
$28,000 a year should I go back to work
the woman
asks $28,000 income with three kids our
health care is provided by Medicaid
which is welfare
Fair because we qualify if I go back to
work we won't qualify for that and if we
go back to work if I go back to work
though I have to pay for daycare and I'm
not sure I'm going to even break even at
least she was doing math
upfront and thinking about it before she
made the
decision now of course her answer to her
equation is both she and her husband
need to develop some kind of a
long-term career path and a short-term
series of part-time jobs and extra jobs
and small business ideas that create an
income that at least doubles the bad
news is they only make $28,000 a year
the good news is with a little bit of
work and Ingenuity they easily can
double their household income and then
they don't have to worry about being on
the government Dole and you got a
long-term game plan to get yourself out
it's not a matter of Simply Her going
back to work that's a limited view of
that situation I actually didn't answer
her question properly when she
called what does all of this have in
common every single one of these things
have in
common adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good Steven
cvy in the book The Seven Habits of
Highly Effective People says number one
habit of Highly Effective People is
they're proactive they happen two things
one of the other habits is you begin
with the end in
mind so when broke people say I can
afford this you know what they're saying
I think I might be able to pay the
payments that's what broke people mean
when they say that if you don't want to
be broke people anymore you get out of
the land of payments if you don't want
to be broke people anymore you sit down
and you say hey here's what we make
here's the size of our mess what are we
going to do to increase our income and
decrease our outgo to be able to address
the mess
faster it really is sixth grade or
fourth grade
math it really and truly is but you have
to get in front of it instead of running
behind it all the time getting in front
of it is you look at your situation
before you make a decision not after
you've made the
decision a
$44,000 SUV when you make $85,000 a year
is
stupid whether you paid cash for it or
not it's still stupid but when you
finance it it's double triple stupid but
it felt good when you bought it and
mama's going to be pissed at Dave Ramsey
cuz her husband called the show and he
said you're stupid and Mama loves that
car I'll just tell you
how many times has that story been
repeated in the last 25 years I'm a cuss
word in some of your all's
houses that's fine everybody's got to
have a gift I've got it I'm okay
but we have to begin with the end in
mind it's called being a grownup you
have to look at the situation and go
there's no possible way a sane
individual is going to make that
decision but the thing is that we're not
sane when we're making half the
decisions because we're operating on
about a four-year-old level meaning we
impulse our butts off I'm tired I don't
want to I don't want to cook tonight
let's go out to
eat let's go out to eat we got to go out
to eat cuz I'm tired I work hard I'll
call the
wambulance we all work hard I'm
sorry if you'd have followed me around
the last six days you'd be in the
hospital some of you we all work
hard you poor little
thing cuz let me tell you what that
going out to eat looks like it looks
like you're 26 years old you make 30,000
bucks a year you're 21 years old you
make 30,000 bucks a year and you run up
$10,000 in credit card debt cuz you bbop
in and out of restaurants you bbop onto
a vacation you can't afford you bbop
your butt down to the pet store and buy
something you can't afford you bbop
through
Target some of you go to Walmart for
entertainment give me a break
you might be a redneck if Walmart is
your
entertainment and no wonder you run up
debt no wonder you can't breathe no
wonder because you got you got payments
coming out your dadgum ears man and
nobody goes in debt 10 listen people
that make $330,000 a year they're 21
years old they don't go $10,000 in debt
in one purchase they don't run they
don't use their credit card and buy one
thing for $110,000 no it's a
,050 thing
it's Death By A Thousand
Cuts and then you look up and go oh my
god what have we done what have we done
how stupid are
we now I'm on your
team I've done it too but I'm just
telling you a lot of the stuff that's
happened in this hour on this show is
stuff that is unbelievably
preventable you just look at it and go
no we're not going to rent our dogs
as a matter of fact we're not going to
finance our dog and we're sure as crap
not financing a cat you know it's not
happening
period period we're not we're not buying
this car honey I know you want a nice
car honey but you know what we're broke
broke people don't buy $445,000 Honda
SUVs we're broke and you know how I know
we're broke CU we don't have any money
that's how I know we're broke well we
make a lot of money yeah but it's all
gone have you not noticed we don't have
any money we don't have any money we
don't have any money no we're not going
out to eat why we're broke we don't have
any money you're not in freaking
Congress you can't just print it in the
basement you have to live on less than
you make and you have to have a plan and
you have to be intentional I meet people
that make $30,000 a year that save money
I meet people that make $130,000 a year
couldn't save money if they had to it
hasn't got anything to do with the
income it's got to do with you freaking
controlling the person in your
mirror it's you deciding I'm going to be
a grownup I'm going to be an adult and
that's if you're 52 you're 22 or you're
12 adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good everybody's
all worried about everybody's feelings
these days I'm not worried about your
feelings I make a living hurting your
feelings I don't give a crap about your
feelings I'm I you listen let me tell
you what feels good not having any dead
gun payments that what feels good having
a pile of money in the bank that feels
good being wealthy enough to be take
your eyes off yourself and not be so Dad
blame self-centered and actually be
generous where there's some room some
margin in your budget and you can give
money to somebody else that's
hurting that feels
good but no we live on the junk food of
finance and and financially we've got an
obese
culture that's lost its
mind and so you guys you have to be
weird normal is
broke The Wall Street Journal says 70%
of Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck that's seven out of 10 houses
on your street and I don't care what
street you live on that's seven out of
10 houses see all those 10 houses in
your mind seven of those people are
broke oh they look good but they're
acting Rich they're not rich it's what
they call in Texas big hat no
cattle don't live like that it's time to
be weird those of you that want a weird
that want to win with money you got to
do weird things cuz normal is broke and
if you do normal stuff you're going to
have normal results it's time to stop it
this is the Dave Ramsey Show now the
stuff we teach here and have for almost
years is
proven it's no longer an
opinion it's not a theory I don't agree
with Dave Ramsey's advice which would
make you
wrong and I know you're writing a Blog
from your mother's basement you're
looking for clickbait using my name I
understand that but you're
wrong and it's always humorous to me to
see people who are broke on
Twitter
ragging on the advice that I give or a
broke
26-year-old journalism student deeply in
student loan debt writing an article
about
me that's
humorous because it's
stupid here's the thing here's the
advice that we give you if you do these
five
things from the Bible and from your
grandmother they're called common sense
you will win with money 100% of the
time now I don't know exactly how long
it will take you and I don't know what
when with money will mean because I
cannot predict your
income and I cannot predict the tragedy
that you will have to
overcome but subject to your income to
tragedy ratio to the extent you do these
five things you will win with money you
will become wealthy in North
America if you will do these five things
over and over
again number one you need to have a
written plan a
budget Jesus said don't build a tower
without first counting the cost L you
get halfway up and you're unable to
finish and who see you begin to mock you
and say this man began to build no one
would began to build and was unable to
finish no one accidentally
wins at
anything and you're not the exception I
don't like Dave Ramsey's advice I don't
give a crap you're
wrong you have to do a written game plan
with money or you're going to lose
second thing is you got to get out of
debt your most powerful wealth building
tool is your income and when you spend
your whole freaking life giving your
money to Banks who fill up the skyline
and have furniture nicer than yours that
makes you
stupid get out of debt when you don't
have any payments you know what you've
got
money do I care if you get out of debt
yes I want you to win I want you to have
a great life but do I care if you agree
with me
no I don't care if you agree with me if
you don't agree with me about this money
stuff you're what's known is
wrong I've been doing this longer than
most of my critics they were peeing in
their diaper while I was doing this
stuff they're
wrong live on less than you make number
three in the house of the wiser star
stores of choice food and oil but a
foolish man delivers all devours all
that he has has if you spend everything
you make you're a fool well Dave you
don't know about my situation in America
today wages are stagnant so why are they
stagnant at your house you know where
wages are stagnant on people who are
stagnant you're only stagnant got
stagnant wages if you decide to stay
there and keep getting those wages this
is not Russia you can quit I don't like
how much Walmart pays I don't like how
much McDonald's pays so don't work there
stupid go to work for somebody else I
don't like how my company treats me so
leave go be somebody there's no reason
that you have to be stuck somewhere
because some liberal journalist said you
were stuck you're not
stuck you're
stagnant don't be
stagnant you know what stagnant pond
water does it grows scum on top you
don't want to be stagnant you get scummy
you need to go be somebody you need to
leave the cave kill something and drag
it
home you need to decide that my life is
not good enough the way it is and so I
am going to control the controllables I
am going to change some things because
guess what nobody in Washington's going
to fix your life Santa Claus doesn't
live there baby have you noticed that
the Democrats and the Republicans
neither one could freaking add have you
ever had any of them send you money
no they are not going to fix your
freaking life you are going to fix your
life you're going to get on a plan
you're going to get out of debt you're
going to live on less than you make and
then you're going to save some money you
know how rich people get rich they save
money wow I don't know if I agree with
Dave Ramsey's investment assumptions I
don't give a crap if you agree with my
investment assumptions you know what my
investment assumption is my assumption
is you're going to be broke until you
save money that's my
assumption you need to get up off your
assumption and go do something you need
to get up off your assumption and start
investing some money 100% of the people
that don't save money don't have any wow
how's that for
insight doesn't take a freaking rocket
scientist to figure this out you know
what the problem on your Investments are
the problem with your Investments is not
your rate of return it's not your
expense ratio it's not no load versus
load it's not your nerdy twisted up
toxic butt opinion about some investment
your problem with your Investments is
you don't have
any that's the problem with your
Investments 100% of the people that
build wealth save money on purpose a
lot some people do it poorly in a stupid
money market account and make no money
on their money others do it wisely in
mutual funds that outperform the S&P or
real estate that they pay cash for that
outperforms the S&P others are just
passive and do the S&P and they all
write books about it and all have a
freaking opinion and make money off of
you while you're stagnant that's stupid
don't be
stagnant invest money save money you
know how you're going to do that you're
going to be on a plan you're going to
get up out of debt you're going to live
on less than you make and voila there is
money in the budget it's called margin
baby and now you got the money to be
rich you got it to act like rich people
and that's not go spend a bunch of money
cuz rich people don't go spend a
bunch of money I'm going to go buy a
Ferrari I'm acting like rich people no
you're acting like a
that's not Ferraris aren't rich
people that's the ultra
Rich you don't buy a Ferrari if you're a
millionaire that's a SE I mean it's
crazy you people you I'm going to act
Rich I'm going to rip people off that's
just a liberal
nonsense rich people don't rip people
off they didn't get rich by ripping
people off that's just stupid don't be
stupid it makes you look bad don't do
that and if you'll get out of debt and
you'll invest and you live on less than
you make and you have a plan then you
can do the last one it's the most fun
you'll ever have with money you can be
outrageously
[Music]
generous so let's see if you were to
invest $100 a
month from age 25 to age 65 or age 30 to
age
70 40 years $100 a month let's put it in
a Roth IRA so that it grows tax-free
and I'm going to recommend a good growth
stock mutual fund that has an average
annual return of
12% I own one that's done that for over
years average now some years it makes 18
and some years it makes
four but the average annual return is
about 20 20 is about
12% for 75 years so let's just say you
did that now I know some people think
that can't happen but this is an example
to help you understand how numbers
work and I've done it my 401k has been
funded and my Roth IRAs have been funded
and anything else I could fund has been
funded because I even though I'm a
natural spender I figured out that I
would have more to give and more to live
if I
saved and invested
and I've done a lot of that in good
growth stock type mutual funds now where
you're doing that in a growth stock
mutual fund were it to average 12% were
you
to put $100 a month
in now what do you spend $100
on I'll guarantee you this 95% of you
listening to me right now do not do a
unique written budget every month unique
to that month
month almost no one
does those that do however find all
kinds of money that's being
lost because your checking account is a
freaking
Civ money leaks out of it like you're
sending it to Congress or something you
have no idea where your money goes and
you make more than your parents
made you make more than a lot of your
friends make and you make more than any
other country in the world virtually
personal
income and you're freaking
broke and so let's just let's just
establish here that you can find a
$100 latte
breath let's establish that you could
find a
$100 Mr and Mrs
cable you spend
$100 on things you don't even realize
you did it you impulse more than $100 at
Target every
month the reason they check your receips
at Costco and Sam's on the way out the
door is not to make sure you didn't
shoplift it's because it's federal law
you spend $200 or you're not allowed
out I think it's easy if we sit here and
discuss it a minute to think about $100
now $100 is a lot of
money but $100 invested every month
every
month from age 25 to age 65 averaging
12% in a good growth stock mutual fund
Roth IRA is
1,176
th000 so if you're listening to this
show and you are under 40 years
old
and you don't retire with a million
dollars that's no one's fault but
yours it's your
fault in this country if you retire
broke it's your
fault because you made a freaking
fortune in your working
lifetime you work your butt off your
whole life and you have nothing to show
for
it
nothing it's
ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous America it is way past
time for a Renaissance in the art of
personal
finance it is way past time for you to
get your freaking act together
for every one of you listening to not
retire a millionaire is
absurd it's
absurd average household income in
America today is
$50,000 if you say 15% of
that that's
$7,500 a
year if if you do
that into decent in your 401K with no
match into Roth IRAs into good growth
stock mutual
funds you would
retire with around $75
million if you say 15% of your income I
don't know if I agree with your set of
assumptions well shut up unless you do
something about
it because my set of assumptions have
made me Rich
so why don't you use my set of
assumptions instead of your set of
assumptions because you're sitting on
your
assumption doing
nothing it's time for you to get up off
your assumption and go save some
money way past time don't you
think so maybe I'm
wrong 72 million let's say I'm half
wrong so you end up with 3 million bucks
shut up
up shut
up maybe you can't save 15% of your
income because you're so deeply in debt
and you've not followed these steps to
get out of debt well then follow the
steps and get out of debt so that you
can but maybe you save half that amount
and so you only end up with oh let's say
okay let's just do this instead of 7 A5
million let's say that I'm 90% wrong
because you're a loser
let's just call it that you're a loser
and I'm 90%
wrong that's
$750,000 you would
have which is a whole heck of a lot more
than social insecurity some of you are
walking around right now and your best
shot at retirement is you're thinking I
sure hope the government which is well
known for its ability to handle money
will take care of me well what a stupid
butt plan is
that that's ridiculous
$100 a
month
saved from age 25 to age 65 is
$1,176 th000 there is no excuse for you
to retire broke 15% of the average
household income in America saved from
age 30 to age 70 age 25 to age 65
average household income being 50,000
15% of that being
7500 is 7.5 million if I'm half wrong
it's $3
million and let's just let's just go
with the assumptions here for a second
okay since we're talking about
assumptions I set you up in an average
household income and for 40 years you
never got a
raise using those
numbers now let me help you with this if
you start at average and you don't get a
raise for 40 years you are a loser
starting at average is one thing but if
you start at average and you don't get a
dime raise for 40 years you're a
loser losers in our country can retire
millionaires isn't that
bizarre that's how Dynamic this economy
is but you're too freaking worried about
the Bachelor or who got thrown off the
island to get control of your own life
and your own expenses and sit down and
do a budget and look in the mirror at
your immature self and say no so you can
put a couple of hundred bucks away a
month so you can retire with dignity
instead of being a burden on society and
on your
children you can't give to anybody
because you're too freaking broke to
help anybody else and you've got all
these great ideas about how other people
need help you want to find out who needs
help get you a mirror you need
help it's time to save money people it's
time to save
money this is the Dave Ramsey
show all right look here's the deal your
number one wealth building tool is your
income all of the millionaires that we
interview unless they inherited the
money which is very very few of them
less than 10% of them inherited the
money did it by Saving and investing
their
income they did not give their income to
Sally May they did not give their income
to Best Buy they don't get screwed
around and give their income to Lexus
and Toyota and Ford and General Motors
and American distress and Master Card
who named that anyway it's a
mathematical thing when you give your in
come to someone else you don't have it
anymore is this hard this is hard isn't
it and when you give your income away
you have given up your economic future
all for crap for a stinking flat screen
for sign and listen let me just tell you
here's the deal you know of the number
of people that start college how many
graduate
52% that's an investment in my future
said the other 48% that are sitting at
home with no freaking degree but by God
they got the student loan debt and you
know how you get rid of Sally May you
either pay her off in full or you die
that's the only way that woman goes away
it's not bankruptable it is not an
investment in yourself to borrow even if
it is an investment we don't borrow
money for Investments we don't borrow
money for Investments I don't teach
people to borrow money the borrower is
slave to the lender that's what this
math says when you give up your income
when you give your income away you have
nothing
all the money comes in all the money
goes out but by God we're sitting around
counting our Discover points oh we got
airline miles oh Sally May's been with
us for 15 freaking years in our spare
bedroom all because we called it an
investment and I don't understand why
it's bad it's bad because it's stupid
and you're normal 70% of the Americans
are living paycheck to paycheck that's
stupid because you're in living in one
of the wealthiest countries the world
has ever known and there you sit like a
rat in a wheel run run run run run why
because student loans are an investment
and I'm going to Best Buy this is just
stupid it's stupid on steroids really
seriously you've got to stop and think
the a level of people's ability to do
critical thought is almost zero good
Lord I get airline miles said no
millionaire ever really millionaires do
I met I've met with thousands of
thousands of millionaires I've never met
one that said you know Dave I made my
money with my airline miles oh those
discover points broke me through
financially hey let's do the math okay
you know how you get $1,000 back from
discover you spend a
100,000 how does spending a$ H 100,000
to get a thousand back ever make you
rich where did you take your math class
really this is absolutely ludicrous but
everybody's counting their dad gum
points and everybody's trying to figure
out some way I'm getting I'm beating up
on check Chas cha your Chase is kick in
your butt their building's bigger than
yours and their Furniture is nicer than
yours you ought to have a clue by now
and the car and I got a car payment
bigger than your house payment some of
you average car payment America now is
$499 that's suspiciously like 500 bucks
if you take
$500 a month and invest it from age 30
to age 70 you'll have what you believe
it you're going to have over $5 million
and you scratch your head and wonder why
you're freaking broke God you no wonder
your kids students have no wonder your
students have student loans cuz you're
driving a dad G million dooll car2
million $3 million car that's what it's
costing you with your stupid car payment
to impress somebody to stop light that
you will never meet and the thing's
going down in value like a rock we have
to stop and think America you have to
think instead of sitting around eating
Skittles and watching Oprah reruns this
is stupid we're fat and we're broke
broke because we have no ability to do
critical thought and we don't stop and
look at what we're putting into our
lives this is nuts it's nuts it's
completely out of control I mean the
number of people I've talked to just
today with $25 and $330,000 owed on
their stupid car it's a car good God
it's a car what does it do it takes you
from here to there now I don't mind you
having a $25,000 car all of my cars cost
more than $25,000 but I freaking PID for
them and they're a very small percentage
of my life a very small percentage of my
income think think think seriously so
credit cards stupid stupid student loans
stupid car payments stupid on steroids
borrowing money on your house to put
granite countertops in somebody ought to
smack you that's stupid it's stupid you
have to stop and think again it's CU
you're killing yourself you make enough
money to retire a millionaire or a
multi-millionaire you make enough money
that your kids ought to have a college
fund fully funded and they can go to
school without being part of the
freaking student loan crisis but by God
you had to have a bass boat so you're
$32,000 in debt cuz those fish were out
running you God think think think quit
being grown-up children walking around
in grown-up bodies adults divide I mean
children walking around in grown-up
bodies adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good this
ridiculous impulsive nature if we think
we're going to borrow our way into
wealth is it's it's out of control guys
we've got to stop this it's killing you
it's killing you while I'm sitting over
here piling up money like it's Dad Gum
nothing and some of you are sitting
there broke why and then going I'm going
to borrow money at Best Buy oh jeez I'm
going to kill you
seriously thank you for joining us
America we are glad you are here open
phones at Triple Eight 825
5225 you can follow me on Twitter if
you'd like at Dave Ramsey uh Dave what
are some of the challenges of living
without a credit
score you know the the challenges of
living without a credit score are very
low unless you're trying to buy things
that you don't have the money to
buy if you don't have any money living
without a credit score is a lot
tougher in other
words so uh
I haven't had a credit score in years
because I haven't borrowed money in
years I mean like
decades I don't own a credit card I have
just a couple of pieces of plastic in my
front pocket I have a debit card on my
business a debit card on my personal
account my driver's license and my
handgun carry permit those are the only
plastic I carry and then I carry some
cash I travel a
lot we travel abroad we uh do a lot of
work related travel uh we rent cars we
check into
hotels um we do all of that with a debit
card I buy things online with a debit
card um I have almost no trouble with a
debit card any more than you would have
with a credit card um I have to use good
sense just like you do with a credit
card in terms of don't interface with
websites that aren't secure and so on
you want to use good sense um but I can
do everything in my life that you can do
except go into
debt and I probably could actually go
into debt even though I don't have a
credit score because of my net worth and
income but uh I mean I'm pretty bankable
would you guess but uh uh but I don't
have any desire to do that um you know
where you run into problems shoot out of
the shoot out of the gate with the
credit score is really three areas when
you're broke and just getting started um
one is to rent some places they want to
see a credit score uh lots of landlords
rent to you without a credit score I'm a
landlord I don't require a credit score
to rent from us um I do require some you
know uh references and I want to see
some evidence that you have paid bills
and can pay bills but it doesn't require
a credit
score um to rent from us and there's
lots of landlords that will rent to you
if you have no debt and you're just out
of school and you got the new job and
you know there's a reason you don't have
a credit score is because you haven't
gone out there and borrowed a bunch of
money which actually means you can
freaking pay your bills and so you're
actually a good renter uh the second
area is to buy a home with a mortgage
without a credit score it's difficult
but it can be done you can call our uh
people we've advertised and been our
sponsor for 20 years Church Hill
mortgage and they can get you a mortgage
without a credit
score now you have to have everything
else in line you have to have a good
solid down payment uh you have have to
have um a good steady time on the job um
you have to be not buying too much house
as a Rao of your income your payment and
those kinds of things it's kind of an
old-fashioned idea we used to do when I
first got in the real estate business 30
years ago we used to actually mortgage
companies actually used to underwrite
the loan meaning they would verify your
deposit they'd verify your employment
they would verify your how long you paid
your landlord earlier on time and you
know there weren't there was no such
thing as a credit score just actually
looked at the human being and said this
track record of this human being makes
common sense as a lending uh process and
that's called manual underwriting today
and it can be done the third biggest
complaint I get for people that don't
have a credit SC is renting a cell phone
as a brand new adult and you've never
had a cell phone and you walk in and you
want to rent a cell phone and you're 19
years old or something or you want to
buy a cell phone and sign up for a
service they're going to require a large
deposit uh that you get back in a year
and uh and they're going to give you all
kinds of hassle because they're not used
to doing it and they're a pain in the
butt now I don't run into that because I
have like 80 cell phones or something
like that or 90 cell phones that our
company owns and they're furnished to
our team and so we have a large contract
you know and so I don't personally run
into that I if I get R to get a cell
phone I just we put it on this massive
corporate account that we have and it's
not a big deal so I don't personally run
into that one anymore and you know once
you've had a cell phone with a carrier
for a while then the deposit is fully
returned and usually it's a year uh and
and it could be like $1,000 or something
but other than that you really don't
have a lot of trouble oh you can run
into trouble renting cars from some
companies with a debit card when you
don't when you haven't arrived at an
airport in other words if you want to go
up in your hometown without having
arrived by airport and just rent a car
with a debit card some of them won't
rent to you most of them will but some
of them won't so you run into a little
bit of trouble with that but it's really
very minor compared to being freaking in
debt to your eyeballs and paying all
your income to a stupid bank and
interest coming out your ears all in the
name of having a credit
score stupid America it's
stupid so the offset is very minor the
the the minor hassle factor in return
for having a freaking life that wasn't
stolen by a bank it's a great
offset it's a great
offset and so I'm amazed at the push
back I get I mean I get hate mail
because I tell people to cut up their
credit cards what a world we live in you
people are
weird some of you some of you people are
nuts I get hate mail because I tell
people not to borrow money to buy a car
I get hate mail because I tell people
not to buy whole life life insurance or
go to a Payday
lender I get hate mail it just is
amazing to me we bail it we get so much
of it how could a Christian do this well
Christian tells people not to get ripped
off Stupid Bird why is this hard this
isn't unbelievable man but it's out
there dude I'll tell you that and so
it's like it's so weird Everybody
worships the altar of the great FICO and
so God forbid someone should Challenge
and say hey FICO has no clothes the
emperor has no clothes it's
mythology it's not not an indication of
wealth
building your F go score only says you
borrowed money and paid it back it's not
an indication of your net worth or your
income or your Savvy with money all it
says is you paid bills and you were
stupid enough to go into debt so that
later you could go further into debt by
building up your FICO score which is a
false measure of Financial
Health FICO has no
clothes the emperor has no clo I dared
to say it I'm the one that stood there
I'm not going along with the crowd I'm
not a little rat-like animal that runs
over the cliff with the rest of you
that's called a limbing I'm not doing it
and you shouldn't
either you need to look around you and
say hey what is the average typical
person who's freaking broke doing and do
the
opposite the average typical person has
a student loan that's been around so
long they think it's a pet they have
American distress they've discovered
bondage a Master Card who named that
anyway and they got Visa coming out
their
ears in addition to that they got a
fleeced car in the driveway and payments
on their stupid bass boat give me a
break this is the average person in
America and they bought a house on a
30-year adjustable rate mortgage because
that was the only way they could afford
the one with the jacuzzi and the
Skylight because God forbid we should
ask how much we only ask how much down
and how much a
month so that's normal in America 70% of
Americans are Liv living paycheck to
paycheck normal in America is the number
one cause of divorce in North America is
money fights and money problems normal
is America Normal in America is I retire
and I say I hope the government which is
well known for its ability to handle
money will take care of me who wants to
be flipping normal normal
sucks well you don't want to be normal
if you got any sense I don't want to be
normal I want to I want to have a sense
of Destiny with my wealth I want to live
like no one else so later I can give and
live like no one else and by the way I
refuse to apologize for succeeding
helping other people succeed if you
don't like the fact that I have
succeeded helping other people succeed
bite my butt America
seriously so here's the deal don't be
normal be passionate go in there change
your life if your broke friends are
making fun of your financial plan baby
you're right on
track if fat people are making fun of
your diet you are right on track track
if somebody who's been divorced 16 times
says you're too nice to your wife maybe
you're right on
track if stupid is the norm you want to
be weird
America this is the Dave Ramsey
show all right you guys what I hope you
took away from all of this is that
normal is broke so if you want to break
the mold you need to say no to Debt live
on less than you make and believe that
you are in control of your wealth
building Journey and when you start
doing the right things with your money
you will impact your family for
generations to come that's it for the
first episode of Dave Ramsey's Greatest
Hits be sure to share this with a friend
who needs to hear it and stay tuned for
the next episode where we look back on
some of the wildest moments from the
last 10 years thanks for
watching